welcome to this video new part of middle
game strategy yeah this is a game played
by mohabbat Vinick again of course I had
a number put Vinick examples already in
my channel but he had has played them so
many great instructive games so it's
really clear that I will have many games
by him on the channel okay the black
player here is Vitaly check over this
was played in the let me check this was
them championships of the Soviet Union
1938 so rather odd game but still very
instructive let's see they played
animals Oh India at the time relatively
new opening and but the NIC played
Knight f3 moves that's totally normal
nowadays but at the time wasn't played
that often castles Bishop g5 yeah here
black played the move d6 which is not
bad but a little bit passive I think um
nowadays people probably would prefer to
play an approach with c5 maybe or even
d5 to transpose to the Rico's in Queens
gambit it's both a little bit more
active putting a pawn in the center
yeah d6 as mentioned not bad just a
little bit on the passive side okay III
Queen e7 he prepares me five we should
be tuned Andy five yeah this is a
typical strategy black puts his bishop
outside of the pawn chain and then puts
pawns on dark squares not very healthy
setup Queen c2 rupee eight castles
they're all very normal moves black now
captured on c3 and white took with the
pawn
this looks surprising at first
but it has a very clear reason after
Queen takes there is the technical move
94 can easily be overlooked and yeah
this is really not something that white
once as now there is this threat of the
intermediate check on e2 and of course
this is leading nowhere yeah white
cannot rescue as Bishop so this has to
be played and here this position
promises white nothing yes this some not
so attractive looking double pawn and no
direct compensation for it so you rather
want to capture on c3 with the board
full of pieces then with the Queen's
traded and so on so this was played B
takes even black know when to age six
bishop age form and I think the next
move is actually a little bit imprecise
black not played c5 and I don't think
that he should do that and probably
better was something like Knight d7 near
97 f-86 trying to break the the pin the
whole thing is a little bit unconvenient
for black anyway but it's nothing
nothing serious yet c5 is not helping it
has one serious drawback and the
drawback is that white has not yet
committed to closing the center and not
closing the center by the way here is
not a particularly great idea because
you want the flexibility to take on c5
or take on e5 it's not leading to
anything yet to play d5 you rather want
to wait until there is some commitment
from black um but vinick's move now is
is strong he played a look a
tewi 881 of course I'm sorry
he played played this move yeah
what did like do now he played Bishop g4
looks like a very normal innocent move
what was the idea of rookie one by the
way this protects the bishop okay and
the idea is white wants to play ninety
two and then push with f4 this is the
idea so if black is not reacting in any
way Bishop g4 is that there is a
reaction to that if he is playing let's
say 97 just to show the idea then this
and this is White's plan you are trying
to open up the fr for the rook black
however played as mentioned to move
Bishop to g4 not this but Bishop g4 yeah
after Bishop g4 now what Vinnie can
starts to play form yeah in my mind view
a fantastic concept that is that
beautifully shows how yeah how free of
any prejudice his positional
understanding was maybe a nowadays this
is not that that's special what's
happening now but it is some really a
really great concept yeah what is his
move now he very surprising me captured
on f6 yeah why would you give up your
bishop before the night it's a pinned
piece on f6 why give up this pin and
seemingly help like by simplifying the
position yeah it has a concrete reason
he took on f6 let's look at this it is
rather forced black of course has to
recapture and now after Queen a fourth
we see that there is a double attack in
place the bishop is attacked and the
poorness attacked so why is this such a
big deal
black now only has two two really moves
he can take on a three this happens in
the game what he can retreat to c8 he
has to attend to this hanging pawn and
b7 if he plays Bishop c8 will not happen
did not happen in the game but if he
would have done that then White's
continuation is very instructive night
to d2 we have a pin on the rook and our
next move will be F for opening up the
rook on f1 very strong yeah that that's
really is really is really a strong
strong idea 96 for example and f1 yeah
and the e pawn cannot take it's a pin by
the knight by the Queen just a great
concept so white 'm has a great position
here it didn't happen like captured on
a3 bishop takes and 96 yeah
the first impression is what exactly did
wide achieve with this series of
exchanges yeah we took on f6 yeah we had
this this straight of the bishop on f3
and it's not quite clear what all this
is leading to but now we see the
beautiful point of the whole concept but
vinik now takes on c5 and this is
basically the echo of what I said
earlier and wide it has not yet after c5
he does not yet make commit to a certain
pawn structure the capture here is
exceptionally strong
the reason is after the recapture which
is pretty much forced white plays rook
t1 and what is the big point now we see
that the defy
square is of course weakened this
happened when black played c5 removed
that I questioned earlier is this a big
problem yes
the reason is we have many pieces that
control one d5 we have chances to use
this square and this is a big point
White has pawns on e3 and c3 that
control D for blacks Knight does not
have an outpost anywhere in fact the
night while technically you would think
that the knight should be okay in the
relatively static pawn structure the
night does not have a good place it
really has no good outpost no no stable
square while white has a very clear-cut
plan look at e1 as we saw rook the eight
and now White's next move is very much
clear there is a weak square on d5 and
we put the rook on this square very nice
control of this we can square and we
also attack this pawn a very important
point is that black now cannot relieve
the pressure by trading if he trades
white takes with the pawn and now after
ninety seven he has the very strong move
and a very very important move d6 with
the tempo on the night so black will
take and white will take here and this
is a typical transformation in this
position those pawns are much more like
a likely to fall and get under pressure
then white spawns this is because this
bishop is also the much stronger piece
the Knight has nowhere to go
it does not have any stable posts here
or here in the center Knight f5 does not
make much sense not g6 is going nowhere
the Knight has no good square while the
bishop helps a lot for example it
supports to get a look to the D farm
so just a very nice position for white
and very important to take this chance
to play d6
and open up the diagonal yeah black did
not capture he saw that of course and he
tried to defend with this v6 and now
rook t1 of course this was anticipated
by what Vinick many started the whole
operation with Bishop takes f6
and this is the very strong judgment
that I was talking about to see that the
series of traits actually leads to
position where white is dominating and
this is despite this seemingly bad bone
structure the point is that pawns are
very nice but pieces are just more
important you know the pieces are just
so strong White has excellently
plays pieces yeah black now tried to
play Knight a5 the reason is or the idea
behind it is that after rook t5c takes
d5 there was always a tempo on the night
and he moves it away and this effect has
a has a concrete idea we see this later
white plays h3 just passing the move
over to black playing an improve
improvement move and improving move
giving the King a little bit of space
yeah now black captured on d5 this was
the idea now we come to a very important
moment in a moment where where many
players now would make a mistake white
here really absolutely must play the
next move but willings move now is rook
takes e5 you absolutely cannot take with
the pawn it looks like the normal move
maybe at first because okay my plot
structure of improving my pawn structure
great but black will get the Knight to
d6 for blockade this is the difference
to be formed here we are not really in
time to play this to capture pawn on b7
or something this is not happening
here black will get the Knight to d6 and
all of a sudden our Bishop it's looking
like a really bad piece yeah it looks
stupid staring at the d5 pawn we should
not play politics but rook takes much
much stronger keeping the pawn structure
seemingly bad but keeping the pieces as
active as possible community 7 black
tries to cover the invasion square and
Bishop g4 yeah rook d7 it's just like
that
the pieces are so active Queen to b7
yeah there's really not not much advice
be given to black something like rook
the 8th
it's blundering e5 him it's not helping
so Queen B 7 B should f5 just very
clearly taking away a square and
starting with made threats Queen takes
e5 now is a direct threat black of
course cannot play g6 as this is
complete devastation yeah what what is
it what he played actually played Queen
to b8
yeah Queen a 8 is a little bit tougher
but black is under under severe pressure
anyway Queen b8 and rook d7 yeah
White has super active pieces
black played rook the eight yeah this
was actually overlooking a little
another tactical possibility Wow
allowing overlooking is the wrong word
the thing is what white is doing is he
threatening Queen d5 and if you get this
in it will be terrible this is just not
a good piece yeah okay he played after
whoop d7 he played this whoop the eight
move after which no White has a little
tactical trick white captured yeah based
on this back rank made this this yeah
Queen sacrifice not a real sacrifice
black took here and after Queen takes b8
Luke takes b8 we should watch this
position again let's take stock it's
equal material but what should Y do what
is the best move now for what yeah it's
clear right you'll take the pawn no it's
not clear in fact you can take the pawn
and it's not not awful but if we
consider Luke takes a seven and black
might just go back where's your bishop
going you're going to not such a great
square now they to d3 maybe it's not
doing that much then what has the
strongness instead of taking them but we
need played much much stronger he played
the move Bishop 24 intending to go to d5
this is such a great square for the
bishop
it's much more important to get them
instead of grabbing a pawn like played
93 yards it's he cannot really do that
much Bishop to g5 rook f8
even the bishop is cemented on d5 now
and have a look at the night what is
black supposed to do with this piece
yeah it really has no no square are
useful robot well white has a very
clear-cut plan what we are doing now is
based on the activity and this is just
fantastic we will keep this pressure on
and we will push pawns on the kingside
why they're here is our majority our
poor majority ultimately leading to a
passed pawn or to an attack and we see
this coming really quickly actually
black tried to use his pawns a six sign
for p5 capture yeah like now we captured
with the night
yeah context it's not not really a huge
difference it's still still the same
thing he took with the night and now
what pushed on e5 f1 and f4 94 King f2
of course not overlooking a fork should
use our king black is tied to they have
seven phone he really has no no defense
to that g5 g three and the trade yeah so
there's not much that you can do 926
very important here is of course that
you really never want to want to trade
only six yeah even if it leads to a
totally dominating endgame let's say
here yeah black tried the c-4 which
looks really AM yeah
it looks like desperation but you will
never ever want to let's say take here
and play this to win a pawn while this
might win it is simply not the right way
to play this in a technical sense we
don't want to exchange this dominating
Bishop against this sorry night it is
the much cleaner way is to push the
console while keeping the minor pieces
on the board we see that this is just
much quicker basically deciding the game
with an attack rook e8 after this and
Bishop c6 white yeah actually yeah black
resigned yeah why'd want me wide one
year I was looking at the score sheet I
was looking at it wrong in the wrong
line
yeah here here white white won the game
like black resigned yeah what to take
from this game let's look at some key
moments black head weakened with c5 and
e5 he had weakened the d5 squared and
white made the use of the square
beautifully him even with simplified
material he made sure that he always
kept active pieces after the capture he
did not take with the pawn after which
I'm not there not to d5 let's delete
this after which the black knight would
get to a good blockading post steady
took with the rook which is much much
stronger keeping the default pressure
with moves like that he had the game
under control the activity of the pieces
and the D fall
here was much much more important than
improving the pawn structure black had a
night that never really got to a good
square note that white secured
superiority here was due to the D file
and the piece activity of rook and queen
if we in this position magically remove
the heavy pieces yeah like we do
something like that then the whole thing
is is a bit different the night here if
it would count to d6 let's
let's put it there just to argument to
complete the argument here it's only
black playing for an edge of course
because there are though no dynamics in
the position the default the the seventh
rank or this is is taking away and
totally different matter with all the
pieces on the board if we go back to
this the difference is the activity of
those yeah d v f7 this kind of active
position
note that the double pawn never ever was
an issue in this game because there was
no pressure that black could apply to it
so a very nice and game showing how
those dynamic factors better Luke better
Queen more activity outweigh this
seemingly structural deficit of the
double pawn also note that it's very
important that d5 is a big weakness well
there is no weakness in the center for
white d5 and also we form our places and
squares for White's pieces that are very
very active while black has no pieces
and outposts that that he can place in
the center yeah the nidus is offside on
a5 yeah I hope you enjoyed this game
it's one of those classic but winning
games where he showed great strategic
understanding and he was far above his
peers and in those times this is 1938
but this even applies to the 50s and 60s
um and very very very very frequently in
games you see that ok I hope you enjoyed
it
thanks for watching